JEFFREY POSNICK:
Hey everybody, this
is Jeff Posnick from the YouTube
Developer Relations Team.
We're continuing a series of
videos talking about migration
that developers might have going
from Version 2 of the YouTube
Data API, to Version 3.
We strongly encourage
all developers
to start that migration if
they haven't done so yet.
Today we're going to be talking
about a way of subscribing
to a user's channel
and show how that's
changed between Version 2
and Version 3 of the API.
So let's first talk a little bit
about how you would subscribe
to a given YouTube channel
in Version 2 of the API.
I just have a page
in the documentation
up here, to just
give an overview
for folks who aren't familiar.
This is the actual RESTful API
call that you use in Version 2.
Everything, again,
is Atom XML base,
so you have this
pretty big XML document
that you would pass in,
in a post request that's
been authenticated, obviously.
And this will end up
subscribing to a given channel.
So that does work,
but let's talk
about how you do that in
the more modern Version
3 of the YouTube Data API.
So, to start, in
Version 3 we operate
on channel IDs, rather
than legacy user names.
And this is
particularly important,
because there are not legacy
user names for every given
YouTube channel.
There are channels
out there that
just have channel IDs
associated with them.
So using a channel
ID consistently
throughout Version
3 of the API means
you can deal the exact same
way, with any type of channel,
even using these
newer channels that
don't have legacy user names.
But that also means that
if we do have a channel,
and we know what the
legacy user name is,
we need to first translate that
legacy user name into a channel
ID.
So let's do that using the V3
API Call youtube.channels.list.
I'm going to show an
example of making this API
call from within the API
Explorer, which is just
a web-based harness
for making API calls,
and just kind of
simplifies things.
It's a great way to
play around with the API
before you actually
start writing code
using our client libraries.
If you wanted to experiment with
what different API parameters
do, I really highly encourage
that you check it out.
So in this particular
case, we want
to translate a user
name into a Channel ID.
In V3 there's this concept
of a part parameter,
that most of our
operations take.
In this particular case, I
want the ID part returned.
Think of this as a way of
limiting the response that you
get back from the
API, so that it only
contains the information that
you specifically asked for.
Instead of receiving a
really large document that
has all the details about
a channel, I'm saying here
all I want back is the ID.
So this is going to
result in fast response.
It's great for
contexts where you
might have limited
bandwidth, or just don't
want to deal with processing
a whole big response document.
So I'm going to
say I want the ID,
and the channel that I want the
ID for is Google Developers.
It's kind of our standard
subscription channel.
I'm going to go down here, and
I'm going to click Execute.
This is making the
V3 API Call for me.
And I'm going to get back this
very small response in JSON,
and it contains this ID value.
So let me copy
that, and I'm going
to use it in my next API Call.
The actual way of concerning a
subscription in V3 of the API
is with a
youtube.subscriptions.insertcall.
I have here the documentation
for that particular API call.
If you haven't looked through
the V3 API documentation yet,
I'd recommend that you pour
through it a little bit.
It looks a little
daunting in that
there's a whole bunch of
different methods listed over
here, on the left hand side
that you navigate through.
But I think you'll find
that all of the methods
follow a very, very
consistent interface,
and naming conventions
that are used throughout.
Once you get familiar
with making API calls,
against one particular
service, using methods
and other services should
become second nature.
So hopefully you'll find
it's a really consistent API.
So, again, in this
particular case
I have the documentation for
the Subscriptions Insert Method
open, and you'll learn
a little bit more
about what's different
parameters are.
And you'll learn about what
you can set in the request body
when you're making your
YouTube API V3 request.
In this particular
case, it's saying
that I need to specify something
for snippet.resource ID.
One of the other nice things
about the V3 documentation
is that we have these
live snippets of code,
that demonstrate how
to make the API call,
using the client library
selected over here.
So Java, PHP, Python, and Ruby
for this particular API call.
So if you were doing
pipeline code, for instance,
you could pretty much just copy
this, and do it straightaway
without having to
change too much.
But I want to show
how you would make
that API call in a little
bit more of an agnostic way.
So we have, pretty
much, the equivalent
of this other page,
this API explorer,
embedded inline in
our documentation,
at the very bottom of this page.
And it's going to allow
me to make this API call.
The other nice thing
that allows me to do,
is go through the OAuth2
flow, for authorizing access
to my particular channel.
It has to know who
I am before it'll
let me subscribe
to a given channel.
So this simplifies things
for testing purposes.
I'm just going click
Authorize down here.
When you're running
your own code,
you're going to want make use
of your own OAuth2 registration.
We have some other
training material
out there that talks you through
the whole process of getting up
to speed with OAauth2.
But for these purposes, we
could just test, using that.
I'm going to put in
part equals snippet,
because I know, from
reading up here,
that I need to set a value
for snippet.resource ID.
So this is my way, even though
this is doing an insert call,
it's saying what
fields I'm going
to be setting in
the request body.
And this API explorer has a
really nice interface over here
for choosing what I'm
sending in the request body.
It's a way of
programmatically building up
my request body for me.
Again, if you're
writing real code,
you're gonna probably be
using a client library.
There's gonna be a
equivalents of doing
this in each client library.
And refer to our documentation.
You can also refer to
github.com/youtube,
where we have all these examples
that are in-line in the docs.
We have a standalone
version there.
So check that out.
But for illustrative
purposes, I'm
going to just do this over here.
So I'm setting Snippet
Resource ID, Channel ID,
and I'm going to be
pasting in the channel ID
that I got from
the previous call.
And I'm going to click Execute.
At this point, I will have a
subscription to that channel.
So that's great.
It just gives me
some information
about the channel
that I just subscribed
to, over here in the response.
And it looks like everything
worked as expected.
So that gives you an example
of how you could make a YouTube
Data API Version 3
subscription insertion.
Once you get familiar with that
basic way of doing subscription
insertions, you'll
find that things
like inserting a new playlist
or adding items to a playlist
or doing a number
of other operations,
all follow the very
same principle.
Hopefully it'll be a
straightforward migration
for you, moving your code
from V2 to the V3 equivalent.
Thanks very much taking
the time to watch this.
Again, I'm Jeff Posnick from
the YouTube Developer Relations
Team, and happy migrating.